with fall right around the corner no
doubt you guys are looking for something
to watch have no fear because i'm here
to help in today's video i'm going to be
guiding you through what i think are the
10 most anticipated new anime coming
this fall now at this point it's already
a shoe-in as to what are going to be the
top shows in terms of popularity but who
knows you might also find something to
watch in the other titles i'm going to
feature let's begin opening the list is
i somehow became stronger by raising
farming related skills
it seems to be a staple in itseki or
just the billion medieval rpg like
fantasy anime these days one mundane
skill proves to be the key to unlocking
a whole slew of possibilities such is
the case for al wayne a young man who's
the best at farming yes
farming and he's so good that he's maxed
his skills out but we have to wonder
what awaits at the pinnacle of those
abilities all we know is at the end of
it all al just wants to return to his
life as a normal farmer not to defeat
demon lords by the power of holy carrots
what yeah you heard that right rune
factory in an anime everyone quite a
nice show so far but a decent number of
people seem to be interested in this if
website metrics are to be believed who
knows maybe you'll be here for the funny
and comfy while relishing in the op hero
and harem because we all know that's
where it's headed
we proceed with more than a married
couple but not lovers
[Music]
that title is actually pretty deceptive
yet quite telling of the premise you see
the story takes place in a school with a
mandatory couple practical course which
puts them in fake husband and wife
relationships under surveillance now it
sounds like a dream come true to teen
romantics out there but there is a
problem people get grouped randomly so
now we have jiro finding himself paired
with his polar opposite akari the
arrangement is also to the dismay of the
girl who has a crush of her own that
she's just missed out on said guy minami
ends up being partnered with shiori the
girl jiro wanted to be with things got
quite dicey didn't they but there's
still hope for all these hopeless
romantics after all excelling in the
course will allow them to swap partners
so it's time for a lot of shenanigans in
order to reach the top and come out with
the happy ending so what we have here is
a comedic situation reminiscent of all
those nisakoi like titles of fake
relationships then add the torah dora
set up if you're old enough to remember
that show looks to be the mandatory
seasonal rom-com and fans of the genre
will have something to look forward to
this fall
[Music]
next we take a look at beast tamer
and yes a tongue twister of a title
that's become customary to these light
novel adaptations beast tamer takes
place in a fantasy world where we get to
meet rene shroud rin goes on adventures
with a party but unfortunately he falls
to crippling over specialization seeing
as all he's good at is taming animals
his party kicks him out unceremoniously
but as one door closes maura opened rin
finds himself now living freely as an
adventurer and burdened by people while
his old party remained unaware how
integral he was to their success one day
he meets a girl from a cat tribe and a
new adventure begins one that's going to
take him through the glorious road to
redemption now this seems to be a fun
high fantasy show that somehow gives me
shield hero vibes maybe it's the outcast
protagonist and be skinned female lead
maybe it's because mad kid is also doing
the opening either way it should be a
nice watch if you're up for some
underdog glow-up stories
talk about a mixed bag of expectations
the whole ninja in modern society thing
isn't too common but the two released
key visuals give a wide spectrum of
expectations you've got the gritty
looking one and then you've got the one
that looks like a rom-com and those
certainly set an interesting dynamic
with the contrast i do really wonder
what we've got on our hands this time
this is the story of ordinary boy itoki
finding out about his lineage to the iga
ninja clan and it's this lineage that
sets him on a tractor learning the way
of the ninja along with that goes a long
conflict between two ninja clans the
eager and the golga itoki must quickly
up his skills if he hopes to survive the
merciless world of rivalling factions
now this one's an original anime so
we've got no source material to base
from still i do think it's going to be a
surprise here with a small but dedicated
fan base the story has some potential
and with the studio that worked on shows
like re-creators at the helm i think
we're definitely going to be in for some
fun
is here to join the fun too
if you were to ask me which classic
titles i'd want to get remade after the
industry started doing it to old
favorites like dora over the past few
years then i wouldn't have immediately
thought of urusayatsura the rumiko
takahashi classic has been one of the
more influential titles in the early
days of anime specifically in
commonplace concepts of modern anime pop
culture like the fan service and the
waifu culture it's got the rom-com
tropes the mix between the fantastical
and mundane and slew of cute original
designs all of which should make the
show very at home in a modern context as
far as anime culture is concerned a
whimsical and charming show that set the
foundation for a lot of modern anime
ursa yatsura is something that you might
want to check out
i'm getting excited waiting for these
awesome for anime and i can't wait to
share more of them with you to do that
me and my team have been working extra
hard to create these videos for you to
watch and i can do that easily thanks to
today's sponsor wondershare uniconverter
wondershare uniconverter is the handy
program that every aspiring content
creator should have it's a catchy
toolbox that allows you to convert
compress and edit videos to your heart's
content as we all know videos whether
the anime we see on streaming sites or
the ones we record and edit have an
insane file size when taken raw but what
if i tell you it's possible to compress
everything without hurting the quality
that's what wondershare uniconverter is
all about whether you've got worries
about humongous file sizes or video
player compatibility this program will
allow you to find the solutions to these
problems a plethora of tools like its
smart trimmer and subtitle editor will
surely make life as easy as it gets for
people who want to get into the whole
video creation thing it's all thanks to
wondershare uni converter if you want to
check it out then follow the link in the
description to learn more and get
started on your exciting endeavors
mobile suit gundam the witch from
mercury is up next
ah gundam such a storied franchise with
a long legacy to speak of remember when
it was super popular a couple of decades
ago the franchise has had varying
amounts of success recently but not to
the extent that it did way back but
which from mercury looks pretty
promising a generally standalone series
which from mercury seems to take cues
from the classic series and explores new
frontiers starring suleta mercury the
story revolves around her enrollment to
the asti cassius school of technology
where brand new adventures are waiter
from the prologue it seems that the
franchise is going the direction that it
hasn't gone before first a full-time
female protagonist in a story that seems
to be going for mecca sentience and
second a heavy emphasis on mecca human
relationship kind of like evangelion
will this be the magic series that will
bring gundam back to the forefront given
the recent trends with mecca anime in
general my early hunch is a no that
doesn't make it any less of a show who
knows you might fall in love with mecca
anime or the gundam franchise after
watching it and if you do so then the
show's done its job
[Music]
reincarnated as a sword is set to make
his debut this fall too
[Music]
we've had people reincarnate into all
sorts of things already in isakai but
the authors just don't seem to run out
of ideas how about pushing the envelope
further and having a protagonist
reincarnated as a sword yeah sounds
about right doesn't it and it's being
reincarnated as a sword that allows our
protagonist eventually christened shisho
to save cat girl fran it's also from
fran where the protagonist learns about
the history of the black cat and the
cruel fate that fran aims to save the
tribe from after showing off their
respective prowess the unlikely duo set
forth in a quest to liberate the black
cats overall it's a very promising show
that seems focused on partner growth and
adventure and you know what it looks to
be my jam and looking at the excitement
from social media a number of people
also think so too can't wait to see how
the two will get to learn from each
other in their quest against the world
whatever
following that how about some fancy
goodness in the eminence of shadow
[Applause]
power fantasies and self-insertion are a
thing for us anime fans right but how
about letting your imagination run well
so that you end up being reincarnated
into the world of your dreams as the
master overlord you've always dreamed to
be with girls to fight for you and do
your bidding while you sit back and play
the mastermind the puppet master of the
whole world ah and bring those evil cold
guys from your imagination into this
world too wait what that my friends is
the eminence of shadow in a nutshell
it's a concept that's rather fresh when
you look at it premise wise and it
surely will get its set of fans i mean
the dark atmosphere the pretty visuals
the attractive characters and so forth
i'm seeing this as the go-to show for
isakai enthusiasts this season it's
chuni it's entertaining and it's got a
strong cast of popular voice actors so
it's just perfect
[Music]
we head towards the end of the list how
about taking a look at blue lock
sports anime well not as commonplace as
battle shows or rom-coms are still
relatively plenty however it's not every
day you see something like blue lock get
green lit while most sports shows
emphasize teamwork friendship or a lot
of those elements of camaraderie blue
lock seems to take the opposite
direction and slams us with the harsh
reality of competitive sports and the
relationship between the self and the
team it's something that yoichi learns
after getting selected to join the
bluelock project in the midst of his
search for answers the rules of the
bluelock facility are simple enough
defeat other strikers and become japan's
representative the cash though is that
once eliminated losers will be banned
from joining the national team forever
it's here that we'll find answers to his
competitive spirits questions perhaps
the selfish play is the right play after
all he thinks will he be able to clear
his doubts and reach the pinnacle of
glory watch blue lock to find out
[Music]
we save the best for last as we feature
chainsaw man
undoubtedly the most anticipated new
anime this fall the chainsaw man hype is
off the roof the announcement way back
already made waves across the community
and as we get closer and closer to
airing the anticipation has only grown i
guess chainsaw man needs no introduction
and the same goes as to why it's so
hyped it's a show that takes you to a
very intriguing world one seemingly
devoid of the optimistic themes of the
usual shonen jump offerings it's dark
violent and edgy all while packing
everything into the very engaging story
of devils fighting each other it's not
hard to see where chainsaw man's gonna
be so hyped and if you're looking to
catch up to speed and watch the next big
thing in the world of anime and chainsaw
man is your pick take note though when i
said it's going to be intense with a lot
of difficult themes i mean it
[Music]
make no mistake this is the chainsaw man
season but is it your pick for the most
anticipated new anime this fall if not
which one is it please let me know
through the comments section as i'd love
nothing more than to get feedback from
all viewers don't forget to check out
our sponsor wondershare uniconverter the
link's in the description it's goodbye
for now but be sure to subscribe and
check back for the next video coming in
a few days